and something that you know I've been so
frustrated I knew this was going to
happen
Okay so I heard about this last night
Jonah's got a fart machine okay so this
is a really bad old-school fart machine
and I'm like wouldn't it be funny if I'm
with all these fancy people and I have
like a really stupid three-year-old fart
machine right oh you should see the way
we all looked at it I was like do I
finish the question my cast mates did
did not find it funny
um then Adam McKay the director of this
giant fancy film goes Netflix has like
formally asked me multiple times to ask
you formally to stop using the fart
machine during press for the film and so
I just want to say officially I love you
Netflix but no corporate entity will
ever silence my digital farts mother
[Applause]
thanks for joining us for ew around the
table don't look up premieres December
10th in theaters